haha
e aí galera to vocês sim ou não nem está
tudo bem só porque nessa tentação
akitoshi tempo todo é olha só de beleza
e até aqui a minha blusa a não ser que
lá aqui na descrição do vídeo tenho o
dado do site cangaço o gasto é que está
vendendo as minhas blusas então corre lá
já na aquele lá e que na na compra e
clica no site já vai aparecer o pai é
capaz então consultar e beber e à noite
recentemente estava jogando aqui com a
galera que jogam online é aonde você
deve saber é que um dia desses eu
comprei o primeiro videogame primeiro
videogame que eu comprei assim meu -
aqui foi um ps3 vez que vocês estão
vendo aqui eu estava jogando aqui para o
jogo vital que sozinho em casa eu
lembrei cali quando era menor lembra o
culto que foi difícil eu teve joguei
nessa vida cá doido tinha oito cara eu
tenho dois irmãos mais é que aquela
história que o irmão mais velho passa
roupa o irmão mais novo pois é mesmo mas
é de todo ele usava roupas uns três anos
vai passar o meu irmão me usar para os 4
anos passar pra mim kato não tem tudo
que não têm noção do que usar uma roupa
sete anos usada por outros personagens
não têm tanta casa não tem noção do
estado indica ficava quando a gente sair
meu pai minha mãe meu irmão e eu vou
falar com o pai mãe olha mulher teus
fita ou bonito mulher e é tão grande e
esse aqui você achará o pessoal achava
que era da pá da zona para impedir o
porto mesmo jeito era um videogame só
que nesse caso quem tinha um videogame
era meus prêmio nunca tive joguei como é
o prêmio de um mega drive eu não tinha
videogame quando meu primo foi teu
nintendo é eu tive medrado meu primo
tempo play um eu tive nintendo aí chegou
o dia que meu primo comprou play do
estado quando eu brinco play do ps não
na linha da evolução eu vou ganhar um
player chegou doido cara pai chegou com
aquela caixa em casa quando olhei aquela
caixa também dois controle branco
eu falei [ __ ] que o pariu ostentação
para eu me lembro como se fosse hoje
teria relatado de promoção do dó partido
não abre que graça eu abri assim 22 o
apoio de um pônei state do doido não tem
noção
você que é novo nessa época não teve um
pólo stay pode state é este aqui eo
playstation e se daqui cada vez têm
diferença visível de visível não tem
diferença nunca naquela época mas não
serviu jogador do futebol do play um
carro buscar tinha cabeça quadrada a mão
para os paulino desse tamanho aqui o pé
do jogador uma chapa desse tamanho assim
olha fala sim [ __ ] [ __ ] aqui é real
de mais [ __ ] é real pune o 2712 não
respeite 1276 [ __ ] no pólo estendido
para botar uma fita é que cabe 8 jogo do
carioca junto a oito jogo pode ter não
dava um cd de playstation e me lembro
como se fosse hoje
nesse dia call matiko o pai abrigado faz
obrigado para o produto que o cuidado
com toda minha vida tam que dá a
proteção divina muito obrigado
ah
[Música]
embora esteja limpa não gostei não é bom
na boca é o menor de uma geração eu vou
vir aqui marcar o outro e doido para um
país que tem sofrer bullying na escola
ainda tem um videogame ainda o meu irmão
tem leite 29 90 e twitter powell época
ao mesmo tempo cheiro e lapa lá porquê
do fla pela branquinho importante
controlar o abuso é igual ao funk lacko
que o o o nome de labuta técnicos
têxteis abtt de 172
o negócio dele é assim
o que gostei felipe e jumar ó jovem
padre e que deus vai ver com dilma na
volta por cima pode ter contribuído eu
queria ofender alguém chamar de pode ter
a melhor até hoje do que há oficialmente
no pé dele falou assim eu xbox você
esteja jogando dá vida a perceber tem
parte de pessoas que jogam videogame tem
o game direcionar ele acha que o
movimento ele acha que o movimento ele
faz no controle da série
ai ai olha só o que envolve toda a nossa
agora nós agora não estou não
ai ai mas chuta e até aqui eles apelam
né
desde então pele e dá um jeitinho
interromper e até pensava que ele vai
fazer é a perder graças a um auto-golo
outubro outro gol fazendo 1 a 0
podem fazê lo
sei lá o que eu vou fazer um gol aqui na
não vão continuar agora e tem também
aquele cara real life é que tudo que ele
faz ele acha que tá falando de verdade
me vou pegar
vou pegar a não morreu não catopés quito
não vai morrer agora vou te dá tiro de
misericórdia
quem é que eu vou nessa [ __ ] e também
assistir televisão 3d não é para dar
realidade nas coisas colocar lenha na
primeira vez que joguei em 3d é uma
honra jogar em 3d é massa de marcelo
eu vou fazer
eu comecei mal aí tem muita gente me
pergunto int você joga um jogo online o
índio passo lento do jogo vocês jogam lá
e sei que olha o jogo praticamente
nenhum jogo online primeiro computador
não vote em mim que eu sou muito no
benfica o jogo muito muito qualquer jogo
é um jogo só de um jogo que eu gostei
pra [ __ ] gostei muito mesmo eu achei
[ __ ] o jogo é baseado no o jogo é
baseado no desenho toy store é um jogo
de tiro só que muito de brinquedo pegar
tudo é grande e aí temos brincam se
durante os primeiros a ver jogar aqui
uma cena pra você ver que nenhum dos
três
então eu gostei papo se você também
quiser saber como é que o jogo o
primeiro na descrição do vídeo é o site
do download do jogo e faz o download do
jogo é se faz seu cadastro na internet e
é você já viu um único todo mundo porque
o jogo fica instalado no seu computador
depois fiz a volta dele para rodar o
jogo online então o primeiro link do
download e clique para baixar o jogo
você embaixo link do download você
quiser saber mais o jogo como é que é
pai para lá passei lá você clica no link
está em baixo o valor do jogo embaixo da
hora do jogo tem o sai da canon é que me
deu esta câmera zinho aqui e quem vai me
dar muito mais coisas cada vez e feliz
pessoa muito legal pra mim e eu não sei
se você já viu jogando algum jogo de
tiro cara do doutor jardim judith doido
é a sustentação da operação tão fácil o
desafio seguinte e se tiver muito
líquido muito light mesmo eu faço um
vídeo jogando o jogo micro acho que você
vê é piração mpe pode afetar o fim de
ouvir que a gritaria é show how to doido
dois não come não fala milhão cara não
me disse que ia sair daqui sem clicar em
gosto nesse vídeo nando e não não tem
senão não fala não fala comigo não cara
do dono foi fé se como tribo shiluk o
troco no click voltei para dar nós eu
quero você comente aqui embaixo é o tipo
de game que você acha mais engraçado e
qual é o game daqui no youtube que você
mais curte eu quero que você deixa que
embarca nos comentários
esse é a primeira vez que está havendo
aqui no meu canal clique em inscrever-se
toda vez que tivermos você nunca vai
perguntar como eu falei aqui na
descrição do vídeo no link da canon ea
loja que me ajuda com equipamento no
canal embaixo tem um andar em baixo
embaixo da cama ou então sai da cangaço
que está vendendo as minhas lado você
quiser comprar um todo o ano pra [ __ ]
você já viu né e embaixo do site da
cangaço é o meu twitter ou facebook
estarão sempre seguir toda vez que
terminou eu boto instagram boto embora o
facebook tem com você nunca tô aí não
tem como você perder um vídeo novo meu
então é nóis e b e triste
[Música]